do you think that the media with the
sensationalism and all that you think
they were responsible in part in
creating the phenomenon of Donald Trump
no I think what has created the
phenomenon of Donald Trump is is the
fact that as the the industry fragmented
with satellite television and with cable
and with the Internet the level of
competition became so great that now it
became a faction I mean a function of
how do we draw viewers and how do we get
more of those of that diminishing number
of available viewers and we do it by
focusing more on entertainment you got
more cats falling into toilet
bowls at the end of news programs you do
it by a a harsher harder-edged
partisan approach to covering the news
and I understand that draws more viewers
but I don't think it's good for that I
don't think it's good for the profession
I don't think it's good for the country
[Music]
you